merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 nous sommes le 2
juillet 2015 et dans l'actualité locale
la première journée de l'open de france
de golf à saint quentin en yvelines les
meilleurs joueurs de la planète se
réunissent jusqu'à ce week end
ambiance et bilan de la compétition dans
un instant et des salariés deviennent
bénévoles le temps d'une journée une
opération initiée par un grand groupe de
cosmétiques depuis six ans qui concerne
62 pays dont la france cela se déroulait
à magny les hameaux où se loger pour la
rentrée c'est maintenant que les
étudiants doivent se pencher sur la
question un forum va se tenir samedi à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
nous en parlons avec nos invités le plus
gros au rendez vous de la saison
golfique en france a démarré ce matin à
saint quentin en yvelines et dans un
instant nous partirons au golf national
de saint-quentin retrouver michael et
demi d'euros d'éclat liaison sera
rétablie avec michael et demi d'euros
qui nous fera un point sur les résultats
de la première journée c'est la 99e
édition de cette compétition
c'est l'une des plus importantes
également sur le circuit européen et
pour l'occasion 60 milles à 600000 s60
mille pardons visiteurs sont attendus
pour ces quatre jours de compétition
nous sommes allez y faire un petit tour
c'est avec william l ça y est le tournoi
le plus attendu des golfeurs français a
démarré ce matin au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
parmi les 156 joueurs internationaux qui
participent à la compétition nous
retrouvons des têtes d'affiché comme g
et mcdowell ou encore le français très
attendu par le public victor dubuisson
il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent
supporter suivre un choc français qui
évoluent sur le tour mais on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya de plus en plus de nouveaux
graffeurs qui eux viennent découvrir un
petit peu la peine son ambiance son
image qu est ce qu un appel on sent une
évolution puis de 3 ans le golf une
discipline qui se démocratise et qui
attire un public de plus en plus large
durant ces quatre jours de compétition
ce sont plus de soixante mille personnes
qui sont attendues
certains restent quand même des habitués
du green a en général on essaie de venir
tous les ans oui parce que c'est
vraiment une manifestation dolphy
qu'importante et et qui nous permet de
voir des beaux joueurs bien tous les
deux depuis trois ans on vient le jeudi
à moins de monde ça permet de voir les
joueurs de 2,2 vraiment prêt coin donc
dans le public il ya les passionnés qui
viennent apprécier et observer la
technique mais aussi les supporters
je suis venu pour voir monfils jouer cet
après midi c'est un très beau tournoi
avec un temps très agréable aujourd'hui
c'est une bonne combinaison
la météo devrait également jouer en
faveur des golfeurs malgré les fortes
températures cette semaine pour le golf
national ces quatre jours de compétition
seront aussi un bel échauffement avant
la ryder cup en place pour évoquer cet
open de golf les résultats de cette
première journée mickaël et demi d'euros
pour la rédaction
michael le nord-irlandais graeme
mcdowell double tenant du titre at-il
réalisé une journée en mode pas trop ou
alors les français sont ils venus jouer
un petit peu les trouble fêtes dites
nous c'est wilfried c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour gamme mcdowell
il est actuellement à l'appui d'al à la
60e place et il est
on peut dire tout simplement dépassé sur
ce premier jour de compétition c'est les
français par contre qu'ils ont créé la
surprise sur cette première journée
notamment avec victor dubuisson pour
nous parler du coût de cette journée
nous recevons christophe muniesa
directeur exécutif à la fédération
française de golf alors gré mcdowell
cette journée est à oublier pour gamme
mcdowell effectivement c'est un mauvais
début tournoi mais on le sait l'albatros
du golf national est un parcours qui
réserve beaucoup de surprises donc il
faut attendre avant d'enterrer si on
peut parler ainsi
l'irlandais du nord pour ce tournoi
rappelons le il est double tenant du
titre l'année dernière ils s'étaient
imposés notamment la faveur d'un dernier
tour remarquable dans des conditions
dantesques c'est un joueur plein de
ressources
donc on va attendre un petit peu avant
de se prononcer sur la suite de ce
tournoi en ce qui le concerne donc vous
y croyez encore pour graeme mcdowell
oui il a vraiment les ressources vivre
avec cette année il ne fait pas une très
bonne saison
l'année dernière on était plutôt en
forme la bonne nouvelle du jour
indéniablement au delà du climat
particulièrement sympathique ici à
guyancourt
c'est le bon début de tournoi des
français et justement les français il ya
victor dubuisson qui a notamment
impressionné et grégory bourdy qui a
également fait une belle performance
aujourd'hui
oui à l'heure actuelle c'est grégory
bourdy qui est en tête du tournoi
il est moins 4 après neuf trous grégory
il lui reste le retour à jouer puisqu'il
est parti du 1 pour victor dubuisson il
appartient bien au plus tôt ce matin lui
est parti du 10 il a conclu son parcours
aux neuf ans - 3,68 ce qui lui avait
permis de prendre la tête provisoire du
tournoi et puis un autre joueur attendu
cette fois ci pas français c'est martin
kaymer le champion allemand qui a fait
69 qui est parfaitement placé pour la
suite de ce tournoi
d'une manière générale un bon premier
tour pour les français par ailleurs et
grégory bourdy premier aujourd'hui c'est
une véritable surprise
non pas du tout parce qu'il joue très
bien depuis le début de l'année grégory
à plusieurs reprises sur le circuit
européen
il a réalisé de nombreux top 5 topten il
est à la mi parcours on le sait le
retour peut être impitoyable au golf
national donc on va attendre qu'il
termine ce premier tour mais c'est de
très bon augure pour la suite de turc du
tournoi c'est également une belle
journée pour victor dubuisson le favori
français on peut le dire aujourd'hui il
a mieux réussi son premier sa première
journée que l'année dernière où il avait
envoyé on s'en souvient les balles un
petit peu un peu partout oui il était
très mal parti l'année dernière sur son
premier tour il avait fait un triple
bogey dès le 1 7 sur le trou numéro un
qu'on doit réaliser normalement quatre
coups là cette fois ci il a bien géré
son départ même si c'est surtout sur la
fin de son premier tour qu'il
enregistrait des birdy et qu'il a réussi
à construire son avance la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il est en forme il a
fait un début de saison plutôt en demi
teinte victor dubuisson l'année de la
semaine dernière par dont il a fait un
beau top 20 à munich en allemagne et il
semble particulièrement bien partie tout
comme adrien stadiers un des jeunes
joueurs français qui sait parfaitement
illustré lors de ce premier tour
il pointe à moins 1 adrien et là aussi
c'est de bonne augure pour la suite du
tournoi les terres du buisson est
également moins attendus cette année
peut-être que l'année dernière est ce
que ça joue dans ses performances
je dirais pas qu'il est moins attendu
parce que le public français a une
relation
de grande proximité et d'affection avec
victor donc le public était massée dès
le trou numéro un pour le soutenir
on peut le dire comme ça ils avaient la
pression il a répondu présent
ça nous fait très plaisir la déception
peut être côté français c'est alexander
levy qui termine avec une carte de plus
six sur sept journées il était très
attendu finalement il a un peu déçu
aujourd'hui oui alors avec les
conditions climatiques du matin il ya eu
un petit peu de retard sur le jeu donc
il n'a pas encore bouclé son premier
tour mais c'est vrai que à l'heure
actuelle il est plus cette même à
l'instant t et
ça va être très difficile pour lui de
faire le cut c'est vrai que c'est une
déception pour nous pour alex parce que
avec une 25e place à l'us open il ya de
cela quinze jours c'était le joueur
français en forme il a mal géré ce début
de partie un petit peu à l'image de
victor l'année dernière il a fait très
chaud aujourd'hui ce que ça pue jeu sur
les performances des joueurs
oui ça a joué sans doute sur les
performances des joueurs qui se sont
élancés sur le parcours
l'après midi en plein soleil les
chanceux ont été ceux du matin qu'ils
ont pu réaliser au moins neuf trous sous
quelques nuages avec une température
parfaitement agréable mais c'est vrai
qu'ici fait de l'ordre de 40 degrés pas
beaucoup de vent exposé évidemment en
plein soleil
ça pèse sur les organismes et sans doute
sur les organismes de certains joueurs
qui n'ont pas été à la hauteur de leurs
performances cet après midi certains
joueurs se sont plaints de cette
température
non parce qu'ils ont l'habitude ne leur
a pas échappé à nous non plus que c'est
un sport de plein air le golfe on joue
même quand il fait beau au golf puisque
c'est un sport d'origine britannique
donc les joueurs sont plus habitués à
évoluer
parfois dans des conditions délicates
mais pour raison de pluie ou de vent
mais non on peut pas dire que ça ait
influencé 2
mer très important que leur performance
même si individuellement sur quelques
joueurs ça pu avoir un impact négatif
merci oncle stick là aujourd'hui vous
donnerez qui vainqueur un pronostic à la
fois rationnelle contenu son premier
tour mais aussi docker évidemment victor
dubuisson
merci beaucoup que sa famille et ça vous
l'aurez compris wilfried les français
sont en forme ici sur le golf national
de saint-quentin nuque et il ya de
l'ambiance du côté du public
oui une certaine ambiance où on a vu à
peu près quinze mille personnes
aujourd'hui ils en voient que le puits
qui l'a sèchement forcément très très
très portée sur les français bien sûr
mais graeme mcdowell ou également ses
fans
ils soutiennent donc les tricolores en
tout cas ses spectateurs au golf et
c'est jusqu'à ce week-end nous y
reviendrons au cours de nos prochaines
éditions
merci à mikel vous êtes avec elodie
moines sur place voire à la technique
autre sujet dans l'actualité un grand
groupe de cosmétiques a organisé pour la
sixième année d'une journée de
solidarité annuel baptisé city thunder
cette journée est déployée dans soixante
deux pays en france cette année 192
actions proposées dont l'une qui se
déroulait aujourd'hui au jardin de
cocagne à magny les hameaux
entre plants de tomates et courgettes
les salariés ont découverte de tout
nouveaux métiers
dans la vie professionnelle véronique et
technicienne de recherche la haine a
troqué la blouse blanche pour une tenue
plus sportive
on la retrouve en train de cueillir des
cocos plat cela fait cinq ans que cette
mort païenne participe au citizen gré
une journée pour les autres j'ai déjà
deux fois travailler avec des enfants
handicapés
ça permet de voir effectivement d'autres
choses quoi d'ouvrir son esprit à
d'autres d'autres domaines également oui
je suis au laboratoire derrière une
hotte avec des gants en blouse blanche
je me couche ça change puis last fm jour
de grand air sympa aussi
c'est que vous avez fait c'est très bien
mais sauf que le clip ne doit pas il ne
doit pas bouger qui est chef de culture
au jardin de cocagne à magny les hameaux
une association d'insertion
aujourd'hui il donne des conseils à deux
managers de la marque
véronique et katia c'est un travail
d'équipé on est tous au même niveau et
on travaille tous ensemble je pense que
les histoires de hiérarchie rend pas en
ligne de compte
c'est l'occasion aussi d'écouter et de
d'être au service des autres et de
d'écouter ce qu'on a à faire et de
recevoir aussi ceux qui transmettent le
savoir aux salariés est ce ainsi un rôle
inversé pour eux c'est super ils adorent
ça
les jardins de cocagne reçoivent
régulièrement des salariés de grands
groupes pour partager une journée en
immersion
le groupe l'oréal y participe depuis six
ans avec l'association unis cité cette
année le nombre de collaborateurs
inscrits a été battu
le nombre de collaborateurs ne fait
qu'augmenter d'année en année parce que
ils se rendent compte que c'est non
seulement un moyen pour les
collaborateurs de se rendre utile dans
des associations de sortir du cadre du
travail et c'est aussi un moyen entre
des collaborateurs de se rencontrer
donc c'est aussi un moyen un peu de team
building cesser ses activités
nous avons tous un rôle à jouer c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui était inscrit au dos
de leur tee shirt la course au logement
étudiant c'est maintenant pour ne pas se
retrouver en difficulté il est temps de
se pencher sur les places en résidences
universitaires ou encore sur les petites
annonces samedi à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines sur
le site de guyancourt se tiendra de 9h30
à 13h un forum pour les aider dans cette
quête bonsoir des greens arnold chef de
service du pôle vie étudiant de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines et en plateau également pour la
de berli bonsoir c'est la directrice de
l'habitat de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on va
commencer avec le forum que vont trouver
les étudiants sur ce forum tout ce qu'il
faut tout ce qu'il faut voilà sur bakou
toutes les offres logement en fait du
territoire donc on a la présence de
quatre gestionnaires de logements le
crous âgées faut ce tu défies arpège et
puis de nombreux propriétaires privés
qui seront là également avec un espace
de convivialité pour puisse rencontrer
les étudiants ils trouveront également
des
et renseignements sur d'autres formes de
logement comme le logement
intergénérationnel représenté par
ensemble2générations et puis sur des
solutions de cautionnement avec le
dispositif clé notamment donc une offre
complète pour ceux qui déjà s'inquiète
pour la rentrée ça tombe bien c'est le
bon moment et autant qu'il soit présent
pour ce juste une parenthèse qui ne
pourront pas être là samedi parce que il
faut sinon ce se déplacer entre 9h30 et
13h il ya des possibilités de rattrapage
vous serez toujours disponible on peut
venir vous voir
rivas notre pôle est ouvert
effectivement aux étudiants toute
l'année donc y'a pas de soucis donc on
au bureau sont dans le haut de vauban à
guillon sur le site de guyancourt
les demandes sont fortes en termes de
logement étudiant aujourd'hui oui donc
nous on voit les étudiants effectivement
tous les jours voilà qui son désarroi
par rapport au logement
un petit peu moins en cette fin d'année
mais ça va recommencer pour un nouveau
cycle on enregistre à peu près 5 entre
500 et 600 demandes de parents uniques
de vos services
voilà ça veut dire qu'ailleurs aussi
donc rien que sur vos services déjà où
on vient assez vous voir assez souvent
il ya aussi un site internet qui a été
mis en place par la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous serez présente bien évidemment lors
du forum ce site c'est 50 ans est ce qu
y pointent look avise point fr comment
ça marche
alors le site le caviste concerne avant
tout des propriétaires qui souhaitent ou
et soit une chambre soit un studio soit
encore une maison en colocation donc ce
site en fait tu es nouveau puisque avant
nous avions un dispositif logiciel qui
s'appelait dispositif champ chez
l'habitant qui était
était établie depuis 2004 on a souhaité
de faire muter et notamment nous appuyer
sur le site internet du crous qui
existait depuis plus longtemps et
surtout plus moderne
donc on a aujourd'hui une page dédiée
saint quentin en yvelines avec toutes
les offres des propriétaires sur le
territoire de saint quentin
quel type de logement ou tel tarif un
peu long trou alors on a des chambres
qui peuvent aller à 430 euros après dans
le cadre d'une location d'une colocation
pécs sur 350 euros par personne on a
vraiment tous types tous types de
possibilités et le mieux c'est
effectivement d'aller sur ce site là de
voir les offres de logement de prendre
contact avec le propriétaire et de
pouvoir ensuite allé sur place visite
est ce que cette offre de logements en
fait elle est complémentaire à celle des
résidences étudiantes dont on pourra
peut-être parler de tout à l'heure parce
qu'elle permet à des étudiants qui ne
souhaitent pas être en résidence
étudiante d'avoir peut-être un milieu
plus calme on pense notamment aux
étudiants en médecine qui souhaitent
être plutôt dans un endroit le travail
le travail ce wiki mais qui attendent du
calme en fait donc c'est une offre
complémentaire aux résidences étudiantes
qui sont sur le territoire mais du côté
des propriétaires ils peuvent s'inscrire
directement aussi sur le site wiki et
pas ceux comme comment ils peuvent
s'inscrire en fait sur le site six ont
besoin d'elle ils peuvent contacter la
direction de l'habitat à la communauté
d'agglomération et notamment à travers
l'appui de delphine message et s'ils
rencontrent des difficultés c'est vrai
que la mutation d'un site à l'autre avec
on a encore quelques propriétaires qui
ne se sont pas réinscrites et ceux qui
étaient là sur l'ancien site mais
surtout il ne pas hésiter à appeler le
site de la communauté d'agglomération
caen la direction de l'habitat la
communauté d'agglomération non les
accompagnants dire un contrôle qui est
effectuée alors que si j'en crois la
tombe est justement sur des offres
il ya une charte qui est signé notamment
de la part des pailles des propriétaires
qui s'engagent sur un certain nombre de
choses et notamment sur la qualité du
logement
sachant que les étudiants nous font un
retour on avait sur l'ancien site de son
60 propriétaires environ on a eu très
très peu de retours négatifs mais c'est
vrai qu'on incite les étudiants s'il ya
quoi que ce soit à nouveau
à nous contacter site internet le
caviste point fr qui va s'afficher une
nouvelle fois à l'écran vous puissiez le
noter vous pouvez y aller dès à présent
pas obligé d'attendre uniquement la date
du forum
on a souvent parlé notamment ici de ce
décalage qu'il existait ces dernières
années entre le nombre de logements qui
étaient proposés tous types de logements
confondus et la demande
il ya une vraie demande il ya de plus en
plus d'étudiants à l'université de
versailles saint quentin n'a cessé de
grandir ces dernières années aujourd'hui
il ya eu pas mal de réalisation de
résidences étudiantes ça a permis de
combler les besoins tous les besoins ma
question s'adresse à toutes les deux
alors tous les besoins je ne sais pas je
pense qu'on pourra faire un retour d'ici
quelques années voir effectivement s'il
fallait que toutes les constructions qui
a pu avoir et les nouvelles ouvertures
que l'on attend encore si ça résorbe
effectivement d'ensemble des demandes
je pense qu'il a un petit peu tôt du
cloud pour avoir assez de recul
il faut savoir quand même qu'on a
pratiquement doubler notre capacité à
terme d'ici 2017
on a on va arriver à 2000 logements que
sur le territoire de 50 ha après il ya
le soin historique de 50 ans parce que
landry non plus pas les nouvelles
communes part exacte n'est sûrement pas
eu des réalisations choisi d'enseigner
une résidence étudiante qui a été
effectivement livrée de l'année dernière
donc là on parle voilà longtemps que va
pas être loin on va être pas loin des
deux mille logements ce qui permet quand
même aujourd'hui d'avoir une offre
intéressante on a des résidences qui
sont encore en projet notamment une
résidence chercheurs qui va qui va voir
le jour en 2016 sur le vélodrome et de
résidences étudiantes une à la verrière
et une pâtes tout près d'ici
sur wii en cours donc on a une offre qui
s'étoffe
parce qu'il a des nouveaux étudiants qui
vont arriver le col de l'estaca qui va
s'installer et qui ne contacte beaucoup
justement pour trouver pour trouver des
logements alors j'en profite
si vous me le permettez ce que là on a
parlé de leca ville on a aussi au sein
de la communauté d'agglomération un
certain nombre de logements qui sont
réservés sur les résidences étudiantes
et notamment sur la nouvelle
résidence au vélodrome qui est en cours
de livraison et qui intéresse
particulièrement les étudiants de
l'estaca on a effectivement des
possibilités de proposer des logements
aux étudiants donc pareil ne pas hésiter
à contacter la direction de l'habitat
puisque on a une personne qui est dédié
justement ce rapport entre des étudiants
et nos places en résidences étudiants on
va juste faire une petite pause avec le
micro trottoir du joie étudiants
rencontrez vous des difficultés pour
vous loger c'est la question que nous
vous avons posé vos réponses belges ou
encore chez mes parents mais je pense
que ça doit être difficile de se loger
sur 50 ans c'est un peu quand même plus
cher je pense que ailleurs après il ya
les long cours je pensais plus agressive
que keith et c'est pas toujours facile -
il ya des choses qui sont faites pour
évidemment mais bon faut avoir quand
même des profils un peu un peu bien
qu'ils entendaient demander dans les
moules et c'est pas toujours facile de
trouver
après il ya des logements pour étudiants
mais après je me suis jamais parents je
me pose pas de questions je sais que
c'est difficile et pas beaucoup de
logements crous et tout donc je sais que
c'est assez difficile
c'est cher en plus donc c'est mieux de
vie chez ses parents sim pratique en
règle générale quoi quand on est
étudiant ou jeune travailleur c'est
clair que c'est super super compliqué on
nous demande des dégâts rend les
garanties de gagner mille trois cent
mille cinq cent mille 700 euros minimum
tu as alors qu'on sort juste des études
ou pas ce qu'on a entendu assez souvent
au delà du fait que ce soit difficile
qui me manque de place c'est que c'est
cher aussi et qu'il faut des aides là
vous intervenez aussi vous aider à
l'université par exemple on est d'aller
enfin on oriente vers l'est
il existe un dispositif en tout cas pour
aider justement ces étudiants qui
s'inquiète détails
alors évidement il y à l'aide au
logement donc qui est bien connu l'apl
sur les cautions c'est un problème qui
effectivement récurrent pour un certain
nombre d'étudiants qui ne sont pas
forcément accompagnés par leurs parents
donc depuis 2013 s'il existe un système
de caution locative étudiants étudiantes
parlons gérés par le crous est donc elle
était allée titre expérimental jusqu'à
présent et cette année elle va être
étendue nous on espère que ça va leur
faciliter effectivement l'accès au
logement écoutez pas qu'est-ce qui vous
intervenez aussi pour les aiguiller
alors pour les aiguiller au niveau des
aides
oui on les informe après il ya pas d
aide spécifique de la communauté
d'agglomération mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'elle se prenne des
cautions notamment quand les parents ne
peuvent pas parce que vous avez un rôle
de médiateur aussi je pense aux
propriétaires qui veulent mettre leur
logement à disposition de ces étudiants
est ce que vous leur dites attention aux
tarifs c'est pas la peine d'aller trop
trop haut parce que vous allez en faire
des étudiants effectivement on a un rôle
d'information
c'est à dire qu'on quant aux 20
logements
une chambre proposé par un propriétaire
qui est un peu élevé alors que ça permet
de prévenir les abus au ceva larmes on
ne peut pas l'empêcher sauf si vraiment
il ya un réel abus de le mettre sur le
site mais par contre l'intérêt de ce
nouveau de ce nouveau de cette nouvelle
page et de ce nouvel accès c'est que ça
permet aussi de voir par rapport au
procès aux annonces du prous les
moyennes et de voir quand quand il ya
des délits il ya des abus particulier
mais on les informe on leur dit
qu'effectivement leur offre est
peut-être un peu trop haute et que de ce
fait ils ne trouveront pas de candidat
juste un tout dernier mot pour conclure
cet entretien vous l'avez évoqué
brièvement tout à l'heure il existe
l'organisme ensemble2générations ils
seront présents sur le forum
là ça c'est intéressant parce que cela
permet aussi de créer du lien aussi
comment ça fonctionne
ensemble2générations donc c'est une
association loi 1901 qui met en relation
des étudiants et des personnes âgées et
donc les étudiants peuvent accéder à des
logements en échange choix de services
soit deux compagnies à ces personnes
âgées pour des loyers modérés voire des
logements gratuits c'est aussi une
solution et ce sera proposé lors du
forum à samedi proposée par l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
et puis le dispositif local fils qui mis
en place par la caisse qui merci à tous
les deux d'être réunis sur le plateau la
suite du journal avec le retour à
présent sur la fête de la ville de
montigny le bretonneux c'était dimanche
dernier au parc des sports de la couldre
l'édition 2015 était intitulé relever le
challenge une compétition inter
quartiers avec plus de 3000 personnes
30 défis différents proposés pendant
cette fête de la ville à montigny le
bretonneux huit équipes chacune
représentant un quartier de la commune
l'objectif de cet événement est de
réunir les gens ne m'ont ils dit les ai
mis mon teint qui vont aujourd'hui
représentée à quartier leur quartier ou
le quartier de coeur qu'ils auront
choisis et de participer à toutes les
manifs les animations qui nous avons mis
en place plus de vingt l'animation
sportive ses activités culturelles et
dix structures gonflables la compétition
a mobilisé plus de 3000 participants en
bracelet de la couleur de la ville
étaient remises à l'arrivée du
participant et une carte de 25 points à
valider sur chaque stand d'animation
golf basket poker scrabble grandes
fresques et handball n'ont pas échappé
aux trois ans c'est bien pour des
enfants il ya plein de jeux ça permet
aussi aux parents deux peut-être de
faire aussi quelques sports je pense que
c'est vrai qu'on a tous envie de gagner
donc
oui effectivement
quand on joue on a envie d'être le
premier donc il ya un esprit de
compétition
j'ai fait tir à l'arc basket et le
torero la fois donc on à gauche et une
vingtaine d'associations sportives sont
venus montrer leurs différentes
activités accessibles tous pour nous le
but c'est de montrer que le handball
touche en fait tout le monde tous les
âges toutes les populations et surtout
que c'était vivant et pour nous de
toucher les enfants au plus proche de
montigny c'est c'est primordial pour les
accueillir après chez nous quand on se
veut être un club formateur et par
rapport à cela il faut aller les voir au
plus tôt et montrer que ben c'est un
sport pour tous dès l'année prochaine on
ouvre une école de handball qui sera
ouvert aux moins de neuf donc pour les
7-8 ans est donc là bas on a déjà eu une
approche et matin on fait un petit
garçon d'un souhaiterait en fait venir
nous voir les cochons le challenge a été
serré de quartier la sourde oreille et
le village ont dû s'affronter sur
l'activité du torero pour désigner
l'équipe gagne
je pense que ça surtout été une belle
journée pour montigny le bretonneux
on va dire il n'y a pas vraiment de
gagnant même si il fallait bien un
vainqueur à challenge mais je pense que
l'essentiel était que tous les signes
montrent un puits se trouver leur
bonheur dans cette journée et s'amuser
le challenge interquartiers et devrait
être reconduit l'année prochaine jusqu'à
demain jeudi jusqu'à demain pardon ce
sont les animations pied des immeubles
les fameuses api qui se déroule partout
en france comme ici à plaisir une
initiative proposée par les bailleurs
sociaux à plaisir elle vu hier soir une
animation dans le quartier de l'aqueduc
mais aussi du vélib ou qui étaient
concernés par l'opération le but c'est
de tisser du lien entre les locataires
le préambule du projet c'était voilà
pour favoriser un petit peu et permettre
à des personnes nous avons des enfants
qui partent pas en vacances avoir une
animation voilà sur le en extérieur donc
au pied d'immeubles c'était un petit peu
ça et puis bon voilà comme ça fait
maintenant quelques années qu'on le fait
rct surtout à des objectifs de pouvoir
proposer voilà des animations pour les
personnes qui partent pas en vacances et
nous c'est un peu le prolongement
ensuite de nos animations sur les
centres sociaux c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous retrouve demain vendredi
pour l'actualité du jour est l'essentiel
de la semaine très bonne soirée tout de
suite fit l'écho avec coeur floral
parfait à demain